thanks for the drive Zeke okay Doc and
to the casino you just need to win one
okay tell Jackie just needs to win okay
tell Kelly more to
[Music]
more interception
you're surrounded by serious threats so
uh my dude what are the rules Oh I
thought you had done this before hi Carl
I ain't called back though wait I have
to play Tom Brady the ability to play
against Skylar Thompson Go Fish no no no
no go bills and I don't even know who's
left the water board year Ray Lewis with
a fake mustache man I said I'm no name
Johnson and I've let it at Minnesota
Southern okay Daddy needs to recoup
massive crypto losses looks like Brady's
tell us that every time he's
inconvenienced he destroys a tablet
stupid thing giving me bad cards
call ah once again bested by my enemy
dboa how'd I do wait wait is this kid
like really good hey man I love your
hair they're there you're coming with me
okay let's see your cards we won please
give me some privacy as I probably mow
retirement
shake and not stir what the [ __ ] is that
all we have is warm Yingling and water
um I can make you a burger if I can find
a grill oh they left
you know I used to coach the Eagles very
cool